welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact the world's longest
commercial airline flight is from Dubai
to Auckland New Zealand and it covers
about eight thousand eight hundred miles
and lasts about 17 hours that's a really
long trip especially if you have a
middle seat take my word for it yet
that's nothing compared to how long some
birds can stay in the air thanks to the
development of miniature lightweight
electronic tags researchers have
discovered that the common Swift is able
to fly for 10 months straight scientists
in Sweden carefully monitored the
movements of 13 Swift's over a course of
two years they noted from these
transmitters three of the birds did not
land even once for 10 months now that's
a long non-stop flight switch can travel
millions of miles during their lifetime
which usually averages about five and a
half years migrating between Europe and
Africa with the seasons they pluck
insects from the air as they fly and
that's how they eat but how do they
sleep evidently each day at dusk and
dawn the common Swift will fly up to an
altitude of about two miles from there
it's assumed the birds take cat naps
while they go eye down but no one's
really sure how would you like to be
able to fly without ever feeling
fatigued stay with us friends we're
going to learn more as amazing facts
brings you this edition of Bible answers
live
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at
1-800-805-3030
and our co-host pastors Jean Ross
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live if you're tuning in for the
first time this is the best possible use
of talk radio not talking about romance
or finance but the Word of God and if
you have a Bible question we got the
lines wide open just pick up the phone
right now and give us a call the number
is 800 god says get a pencil here we go
again 800 for 6 3 7 2 97 that will bring
your Bible question into the radio this
is a live program and so if you have a
question very good chance you'll get
your call on the air tonight if you pick
up the phone and call with your Bible
question now here's the number again 800
God says that's 800 for six three
seventy to ninety seven 800 for six
three seven 297 with your Bible
questions and I'm Doug Batchelor my name
is John Ross good evening friends and
past Doug once again let's start the
program with a word of Prayer
dear father we thank you that we have
this opportunity to open up the Bible
and study together and we asked for your
blessing upon this program be with those
listening Lord and together may we
search the scriptures for truth in Jesus
name Amen amen
well pastor that you opened the program
by talking about a remarkable little
bird that can fly an incredibly long
distance not only a long distance but I
guess able to stay up in the air not
just for a few weeks but amazingly 10
months that's hard to imagine it is it's
incredible now I you know I've known
that birds like the great frigatebird
that's a sea bird they can fly for weeks
without landing and they you know they
kind of go down and they scoop sardines
during the day from the ocean and they
they fly up high and they I guess those
make a big wingspan they
those while they're gliding up there I
say orsten sleep standing up but I had
never imagined there was a bird that did
not touch down look in months
night and day storm wind and it just
it's mind-boggling when you think about
it and you know it made me think about
that verse in the Bible that's in Isaiah
40 verse 31 it'd be nice never to get
tired those that wait on the Lord shall
renew their strength they will mount up
with wings like eagles they will run and
not be weary they will walk and not
faint you know I've read some reports
that people are more caffeinated today
than they have ever been in history I
mean it's not just the coffee and the
tea there's just gobs and gobs of
different energy drinks ago I'm energy
drinks or just get caffeinated drinks
and people are just looking for energy
and in a lot of people out there feel
spiritually fatigued and they want to
know how do I get some spiritual energy
how do I get revived well we've got
something that we'd like to share with
you friends that will give you a
spiritual boost it'll put some wind
under your wings and it's a book on
revival the book is called twelve steps
to revival and we'll be happy to send
this resource to anybody who calls and
asks again the book is called twelve
steps to revival and the phone number to
call this is our resource phone number
is 883 five six seven four seven again
that number is 885 six seven four seven
you can ask for a free offer this
evening a book called twelve steps to
revival we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who calls and asks and if you
have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven again that's 800
four six three seven two nine seven
that'll bring you hearing to our studio
and we'll be able to get your question
on tonight's program one more time
here it is 800 for six three seven two
nine seven well we're gonna go to the
phone lines our first caller this
evening is Robert and he's listening
from Riverside California
let's see if we can get Robert on the
phone well not just yet I think they
still getting something done they're on
the other side but pastor Doug you know
on my way driving here to the studio
this evening you couldn't help but
notice all of the stores with the
skeletons and the ghosts hanging out
front already and you know a lot of
folks are asking questions around this
time of the year or what happens to
people when they die
well the Bible has something to say with
reference to the subject and amazing
facts has a website that deals with some
important questions that people ask can
the Dead come back what about ghosts and
where do they come from we have a
website called ghost truth com that's
right and it'll answer a lot of
questions people wonder if during
Halloween about seances and death and
and are they being spooked by real
ghosts not kids in a in a sheet so just
go to ghost truth and it gives you Bible
answers on what happens you can do
people turn into ghosts after they die
you'll find it very interesting all
right I think we're all ready Robert in
Riverside California Robert you on the
air yes hi thank you for calling yeah
thank you guys I love you Jill I have a
scripture I hope you can find I forget
exactly where and it's given one of the
Gospels but it's always come to mind and
I just thought of it and I thought well
why not give it a try it's bothering for
a lot of times this where the disciples
at one time they said we're going down
to a festival feast I forget which one
it was but of something going on and I
said we're going down would you come
would you like to come with us
did you to Jesus and he said no I think
they'd asked him like twice but I'm not
sure but anyway it says and then later
Jesus went down in secret right I think
it's the Gospel of John right I couldn't
figure out what this mean is this mean
that he's lying
yeah the Gospel of John chapter 7 is I
think the verse that you're looking for
and in pastor Ross I just had it a
second
there was a feast and his brothers had
gone to the feast and it says after this
let me see here yea it's John 7 and
verse 8 he said you go up to the feast I
am NOT going up to this feast for my
night my time is not yet fully come and
after this saying he remained in Galilee
but after his brothers had gone up to
the feast then he also went up not
publicly but in private is that the
verse you're looking for yeah I went
secret number doesn't say he went secret
I think one whatever Bible I was reading
one time I found I guess yeah it's the
same he went in a clandestine way see at
this point Jesus was becoming very
popular through his miracles and he knew
his brothers were trying to push him
into announcing he was the Messiah and
he said you know if you why do you do
these things secretly if you're from God
let everyone know and he said no it
causes a ruckus I want to they want to
mess up his ministry because it would
draw too much attention from his enemies
you know I'm reading this here in the
King James actually it's the New King
James that I'm reading and it's verse 8
in particular it says you go up to the
feast Jesus is talking and he says I am
not yet going up to the feast for my
time is not yet fully come now that's
the way the King James and New King
James translated but there are some
newer translations that I'll mitt the
word yet and that does give the
impression and that Jesus said he would
not go and then suddenly went in secret
but that's not what we read here in the
Textus Receptus for the King James yeah
new King James original technique James
says he but he went as it were in secret
it uses that word so hey that's I'm glad
we were able to find it I'm pretty sure
that's the only place this appears in
the Bible Robert and if I'm not mistaken
that's the verse that you were looking
for and so Jesus was just trying to
preserve his freedom to minister in
Jerusalem without being stopped or
blockaded because they were gonna have a
big crowd now later in his ministry at
the end of his ministry he did make a
triumphal public entrance to Jerusalem
and it did kind of outrage the religious
leaders appreciate your call Robert that
Mexico days Anthony listening from
Washington DC Anthony welcome to the
program
how're you doing sir doing well thank
you for calling and your question I was
just trying to do interpret Matthews
twelve verse 25 and 26 we'll do our best
Matthew 12 25 and 26 yes all right it
says in Jesus knew their thoughts and
said to them every Kingdom divided
against itself is brought to desolation
and every city or house divided against
itself shall not stand and if Satan cast
out Satan he is divided against himself
how shall his kingdom stand well they
were accusing Jesus of casting out
Devils through the devil and Jesus was
saying you know your logic is flawed
because if the devil is attacking
himself he's not gonna have a very
effective Kingdom and see they said in
verse 24 this fellow casts out Devils
but by Beelzebub the Prince of devils
and so he was just illustrating that
they're making a big mistake by assuming
that he was doing this work of God of
setting people free by the devil now
that's not to say that there aren't
times when Satan has counterfeit healers
that will look like they're casting out
Devils but they're not you know what I'm
saying so the devil does sometimes use
fake representatives that are wolves in
sheep's clothing but Jesus was
addressing a different principle here
that he it doesn't make sense for the
devil to cast out the devil and I wanted
to say this I'm having a problem finding
out who to vote for because you have the
Democratic and you had the Republican
and I was wanting to know does that
scripture ties into the boat well you
know the Bible tells us to obey the laws
of the land and we have the privilege as
a representative country to choose our
leadership and you know we've got to be
careful during this program not to tell
you who or how to vote for because we
already have our hands fault talking
about religion we don't know mix it with
politics right now
but you know I think you need to look at
not just the the rhetoric of what you
hear during an election but you need to
think about what will these candidates
do with the court what will they do with
certain principles that would affect the
freedom to proclaim and practice your
religious conviction and you know that's
what I tell people is Sam you know look
at what it's going to do to the freedom
of the proclamation of the gospel and to
having a country where the court judges
will support some morality anyway that's
probably all I better say all right well
thanks you a col Anthony if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 804 six three seven two
nine seven again that's 804 63 72 97
with your Bible question our next call
is Lois listening in sorry Lois is
listening in Las Vegas
Lois welcome to the program hello hi
thank you for calling Lois you're on the
air
hi good evening possible evening pause
for us god bless both of you I just
started to listening to your program and
radio 74 since the beginning of the year
and I listened to it you know when I'm
home because the work at night which I
don't enjoy very much anyway
oh I'm sorry
no you're questioning where we
appreciate your call I was calling to
find out what chapter could have found
about well I guess not wearing jewelry
because I was having a conversation with
my friend our church she said I mean I
work on she's a dear / weakness and she
said to bring the chapter in the Bible
I'm sure through we're really not
supposed to wear jewelry probably a ring
or watch I don't know if I'm right so
I'm calling in to find out if you could
help me well there is there are several
verses in the Bible that give a
principle of modesty and dress and
pastor Ross might look up some of them
for me real quick thing one is
you're gonna find in first Peter chapter
3 where it's talking about Christian
wives should not have the outward
adorning the wearing of gold Paul says
in is it the first or second Timothy
says not with gold or pearls or costly
array first Timothy chapter 2 verse 9
verse 72 verse 9 first - pretty much you
go to chapter 9 no chat up - to verse
nine 9 okay you know of course you know
the story where the children of Israel
made a golden calf and you read about
that and I think Exodus 32 and they made
the golden calf from jewelry and then
after they made the calf and they were
told to grind it to powder and Lord made
him drink it God told the children of
Israel break off your ornaments and
pastor Ross might find that verse for me
he said break off your ornament so I can
know what to do with you you know the
other verse referring to just as a quick
cross reference it's mentioned twice in
the New Testament the other one is 1st
Peter chapter 3 verse 3 through 6 okay
you have Timothy 1st Timothy 2:9 and
then also 1st Peter chapter 3 beginning
in verse 3 very okay and then you've got
there's several other verses you know
what we ought to do just to get you the
best resources Lois if it's okay with
you I will send you a book I've written
on the subject and it's called jewelry
how much is too much because I think
most Christians agree that a person can
go overboard and the question is what is
overboard what did where is that line
and so if you'd like a free copy of the
book it's got all these references in
the book and you can even share with
your friend after you read it just call
our resource number then I'm gonna call
these eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the
book called jewelry how much is too much
again the number is 883 five six seven
four seven that is the resource phone
number
as for the free book jewelry how much is
too much and if you have a Bible
question I've online here to the studio
once again he's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven eight hundred
four sixty three seventy to ninety seven
that'll bring you here into the studio
with your Bible question my next call a
Samuel listening in San Diego California
Samuel welcome to the program oh well
thank you good evening my question is
more about a translation difference
between the New King James Version and
two other actually other modern version
that are talking about the righteousness
through faith in Christ Romans 3:21 and
3:22 talk about the faith being revealed
or actually said the righteousness of
God had revealed and then it goes on
through faith in Christ when you read
the new English testament any T uh-huh
it says that through Christ's
faithfulness not through your
faithfulness in Christ or your faith in
Christ but rather because of Christ's
very own faithfulness that we are saved
and to me those statements are
completely different I mean I understand
that the Son of God was faithful left
until death and I mean through death and
all that but when we're talking about
personal salvation I always thought that
it was the believers belief in Christ
that got him you know placed in Union
through the Holy Spirit into the body of
Christ and that that was you know the
righteousness by faith because Paul goes
on and talks about that in the fourth
chapter I do you want me to try to
answer this I think I got your question
here yeah there's several translations
that you're gonna find in English that
may render this verse a little different
but you're right the nuances are very
important my favorite translations would
be King James New King James and that
does continue with the
idea that it has something to do with
our faith in Jesus and it says even and
this is verse 22 in the New King James
even the righteousness of God through
faith in Jesus Christ to all and on all
who believe so it's talking about us
believing us having faith so you know
the translations say that it is a faith
of Jesus there's you know now you you in
wears it pants are awesome revelation
that says one place keeping the
commandments of God in the faith of
Jesus the faith of Jesus revelation
14:12 yeah and other places I talked
about faith in Jesus so the way I've
heard this explained is we're supposed
to have the faith that Jesus had in the
Father we have in Christ so it's like
the faith of Jesus and he gives us this
gift of faith so in in one way it could
be semantics but you're right we are
saved by choosing we have a free will to
exercise faith in God's promises that's
why you know man came to Jesus 1 since
the Lord if you can heal my son he said
if you believe all things are possible
in others you must choose to believe so
does that make sense Samuel absolutely
and I appreciate your time yeah thank
you very much for your question good
question
my next Coley's Ron listening in
Washington Ron welcome to the program
hi Ronnie on the air how are you guys
doing we could hear ya okay great I my
question is about the great heavenly
hosts the scriptures that says that the
great heavenly hosts are looking out
upon us and I was wondering who are
these Moses and Elijah well I think you
might be talking about you know there's
one place where it says in Hebrews
seeing that we were surrounded by such a
great cloud of witnesses that's probably
another verse you're talking about that
that's talking about the examples of the
faithful through history
other places where it talks about a
heavenly host watching you've got in the
book of Job
it talks about you know the angels and
the leaders of unfallen worlds that look
down on what's happening in earth and
then Paul I think talks about us being a
spectacle to the universe to men and
angels and so you know he gives us the
idea that there are unfallen of course
there's also fallen angels called demons
and devils when there's unfallen angels
in these heavenly intelligences that are
watching they can see what's happening
in this world
don't think they aren't the they aren't
the actual ancestors no I don't believe
so because first of all there's a few
rare exceptions like where God took
Elijah to heaven and Enoch and Moses was
resurrected but the general resurrection
of the Dead happens when Jesus comes it
says when the Lord descends from heaven
the dead in Christ rise and that's in
1st Thessalonians 4 and Jesus said the
resurrection on the last day I think
three times in John chapter 6 he says on
the last day I will raise them up and so
the idea that all these dead people are
up in heaven watching right now like
they're in a some kind of balcony
seating that's really not taught in the
Bible it says Jesus said our friend
Lazarus is asleep but then he said he
was dead so if you're saved let me just
simple this confuses people because you
can walk through any kind of church
cemetery and you're gonna see some
tombstones will say our beloved mother
is now walking the golden streets and
another tombstone will say our mothers
sleeping in the arms of Jesus resting in
peace that's where you get our IP on the
tombstones there what confuses
Christians Paul says to be absent from
the body is to be present with the Lord
what that means is if you're a believer
and if you die the you next conscious
thought you have is the resurrection you
haven't been resurrected yet because in
this world we still live in time and it
has the event hasn't occurred yet so for
us no they're not up there year you know
spying on us there it says we're caught
up to meet the Lord in the air together
we
are caught up so this mass resurrection
happens when Jesus comes and I'm again
first Corinthians chapter 15 verse I
forget the verse it says in the
resurrection at the coming of Christ
anyway I don't know does that help a
little bit wrong hey we'll send you
we've got a book that talks about are
the dead really dead we'll send you a
free copy all you'll have to do is give
us a call on our resource phone number
the number there is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the study
guide called AHA the dead rarely dead
we'll be able to send this to you Ron or
anybody who calls and ask for important
subject and a great study we also have a
website dealing with us called
death death truth calm just death truth
but a lot of great scriptural references
there as well I next call is Derek and
he's listening in Jacksonville Florida
Derek welcome to the program good
evening thank you for your patience good
evening thank you for taking my call
appreciate it and your question okay the
question is when know Jesus died on the
cross did the Angels who are watching
this today know that he was gonna be
coming back or the day during the time
where he was asleep did they really
think that he was gone for good well see
the angels were able to hear what Jesus
said while he was alive and Jesus told
the disciples on several occasions I'm
gonna go to Jerusalem I will be betrayed
into the hands of the Gentiles they will
crucify me and I will rise the third day
so Jesus had often repeated that the
angels heard that they of course were
optimistic angels have faith that Jesus
would but it was very troubling for them
to see their Savior suffering and him
die and and to be placed in a grave but
I think they did have the knowledge that
he would rise of course the angels were
the ones that rolled away the stone and
met the disciples when they came to the
tomb so I think they were in on the plan
still there Derek does that make sense
you there yeah I'm here
okay did that that makes sense that
makes perfect sense I was I was
wondering American only imagine the
Greeks that they must have felt seeing
that happen
yep I I'm with you hey we really
appreciate your phone call and we do
have a lesson that talks about angels is
called angel messages from outer space
we'll be happy to send you that actually
thank you very much
okay the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone number and you can ask for the
study guide called angel messages from
space we'll be able to send there to
anybody who calls and asks again that
number is 885 six seven four seven if
you have a Bible question the phone line
here to the studio it's a good time to
give us a call is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven again that's 800
four six three seven two nine seven you
know past that I can think we coming up
on our med program break in just a few
moments but again friends is a good time
for you to pick up your phone and give
us a call and be ready with your
question for the second part of our
program yeah best is yet to come don't
go away we see those of you who are
standing by and we're gonna get your
phone calls in just a few moments do
also have a couple more lines open eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven we're going to take a breath and
get a drink of water and we'll be back
and just took two minutes and take more
bible questions
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
Doug Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is
a video Bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your ethnic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
855-578-6767
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live we still have a few phone
lines open if you have a Bible related
question call us at one eight hundred
seven eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven now let's join pastors
doug batchelor and john ross for more
Bible answers live we are back and we
are live and we're gonna go to the
phones in just a moment do you have one
or two lines open that number 800 God
says 800 for six three seven two nine
seven the truth will set you free
so every question you ask and learning
the truth makes you even more free i'm
doug batchelor us and pastor doug we
ready to go to the phone lines our next
caller is Matt and he's listening from
British Columbia Matt welcome to the
program thank you sir
thank you yeah my my question is about
the harlot now you're talking about
revelation 17 Paul is in vision and he
describes a woman who is sitting on a
beast with seven heads and ten horns and
it says that she's arrayed in scarlet
and purple and precious stones and yet
she got a name on her foreheads is
Babylon the Great the mother of harlots
and abominations of the earth
that woman represents a great
counterfeit or unfaithful religious
system then you have another woman in
Revelation 12 who is pure she is clothed
with the Sun and the moon and a star as
the light of God the woman in revelation
17 is called a harlot because she has
become unfaithful and it says she sits
among seven mountains well there's a
clue it says that woman is the city that
sits on seven mountains well there is a
major Church that is in a city called
Rome that is called the city of seven
hills that has become unfaithful to
biblical truth the Frances the Bible
says do not make idols
bow down to them and of course we know
that in the Catholic system there's a
lot of idols that are made a lot of
people bowing and praying before idols
of Joseph or Mary or Peter and Bible
says that only God can forgive sin and
yet you know they say that you need to
confess your sins to the priest and the
priest can absolve you of your sins in
some form it says this is a persecuting
power the Catholic Church agrees that
during the dark ages they were
responsible for persecution because you
know pope john paul ii publicly
apologized for what the church did and
that was back in 2000 and so i could go
through a list of about a dozen things
that most reformed theologians now if
friends this is not pastor Doug I'm
talking John Wesley John Calvin Martin
Luther Knox melanchthon Spurgeon all of
these great reformed preachers and
pastors believed the woman in revelation
17 was the Roman Catholic Church there
are a lot of lovely spirit-filled the
Catholic people I'm not trying to be
critical I'm just telling you what the
prophecy was talking about what happened
yeah and so there's your answer we do
have a we do have a book we'll send you
on that and it's free it's it's a book
called the beasts the dragon and the
woman very popular book as it just has a
great way Joe Cruz did a great job of
explaining this again the number two
Coley's 808 three five six seven four
seven you can answer the book called the
beast the dragon and the woman eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven that is the resource phone number
and if you have a Bible question the
phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven my next call is Kurt listening
from shamrock Texas Kurt welcome to the
program yeah loud and clear thanks for
calling Kurt I have a question for you I
listened to Chuck Smith's from Calvary
Chapel and he had a DVD called wisdom of
the ages and he talks about the
different Bible versions and he talks
about the corruption of all the newer
versions and that the King
Jameses is the one that hasn't been
corrupted by the Satanic policy of evil
and another and if you look at
Colossians 2:18 the King James says
specifically you have not seen angels
and all the other verses say that you
have seen angels and if Scripture is
inspired by God and then one of those
one of them is right I mean you can't
you can't have contrary doctrines and in
the Bible so what what what do you say
about that all righty I appreciate that
Curt there are some pastors out there
and and if it's the same Chuck Smith I'm
thinking of he was a good man he you
know one of the founders of Calvary
Chapel and I think he's passed away now
but there's some that they call them
King James only pastors I am NOT in the
camp of King James only
I don't believe pastor Ross is either
but we are in the camp that there's a
big difference in translations and
that's because most of the modern
translations incorporate manuscripts
that the the early reformers felt were
doubtful the King James New King James
new American Standard they are
translated from what's called the Textus
Receptus the NIV and some of the other
translations used not only the Textus
Receptus but they use doubtful
manuscripts called the Vaticanus that
one came from the Vatican and the signee
Atticus that came from a monastery on
naked st. catherine's monastery on mount
sinai and there was some you know the
90% no more than that was like 99% of
all of them are the same but there was
some little doubtful spots in those
other manuscripts and so typically when
I preach or do evangelism I use either
the King James in the New King James New
King James is very much like the King
James that just modernized some of the
words instead of like ye it'll say you
but the structure of the of the
sentences is going to be almost
identical but you're right there is
there is some differences now I don't
believe that King James was flawless the
King James was also translated by a grue
of scholars and they made a few mistakes
just little things with punctuation but
I do believe the word of God is perfect
and if you're in danger of believing too
much or too little believe too much of
it don't start to question it you know
we do have a book dealing with the Bible
called the ultimate resource and it
talks about the scripture and how we can
understand it and a little bit of the
background of how he got the Bible so
we'll be happy to share this with you
Curt or anybody wanting to learn more
about the Bible is called the ultimate
resource on the phone line he's eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven and again asked for the book the
ultimate resource written by pastor Doug
808 three five six seven four seven and
next Koli is a Sanja listening from New
York
Sanja welcome to the program Sonja are
you there it's more childish praise for
the father and are we going to well let
me read you a few verses in 1st
Corinthians 13:12
for now we see through a glass darkly
but then face to face and you can read
in oh if you go to Revelation it says
and God Himself will be with us and we
will see him and so I believe we will
see God the Father and God the Son face
to face let me be more sure ok yeah it's
going to be probably the most thrilling
thing that could happen is to be able to
see the face of God in the kingdom and
I'm looking forward to be
there right yeah let me in revelation 22
for one of the last chapters in the
Bible and it says and God let me see
here and there shall be no more curse
but the throne of God and of the lamb
the lamb is Jesus God and the lamb shall
be in it and his servants will serve Him
and they shall see his face that's
pretty clear isn't it pretty clear okay
yep so you can read that last chapter in
the Bible revelation 22 and you'll
you'll find those words and a great
encouragement there
I appreciate your call Sonja my next
hole is Robert listening from college
place Washington Robert welcome to the
program
I do thank you welcome hi my question
was from Galatians 5:4 and it talks
about keeping the commandments if we
keep the commandments we've fallen from
grace you know I don't believe he's
saying let me read this for you if you
look in verse 3 Galatians is not talking
about keeping the Ten Commandments it's
talking about being believing that
you're saved by keeping especially the
ceremonial laws because you look it says
in verse 3 I testify again to every man
that is circumcised he is a debtor to do
the whole law Paul is talking about the
ceremonial law obviously Paul is not
saying don't obey the commandment that
says thou shall not lie I want you to
start lying because if you don't lie
you're not saved Paul is not saying you
need to start committing adultery and
you need to start murdering because if
you don't if you're keeping those laws
you're not saved you see what I'm saying
so obviously the Apostle Paul would
never tell believers he'd never
encouraged them to break the Ten
Commandments the battle in Galatians is
over the ceremonial laws that the Jewish
Christians were telling the new Gentile
Christians they needed to keep the feast
days and they needed to be circumcised
dan and Paul was saying look if you
think you're saved by by all these
sacrifices at the temple the blood of
goats is not going to wash away your sin
it's only
the blood of Christ you are lost if
you're trusting in those things
Paul was never saying it's now okay to
break the Ten Commandments because you
can see how absurd that would be for him
to say yes of course you can use God's
name in vain and if you're teaching
people don't use the name of the Lord in
vain for him to say well you're not
saved if you're teaching that because
Jesus said whoever shall do and teach
the commandments is great in the kingdom
of heaven that's Matthew chapter five
does that make sense
and then he cool thank you yeah so yeah
but Galatians the big discussion there
is really dealing with the ceremonial
law now we have a book we can send
Robert talking about does God's grace
blot out the law and we'll send you a
free copy Robert just give us a call on
our resource phone number the number is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask the study guide called does God's
grace blot out the law again that number
is 885 six seven four seven and as for
the study guide does God's grace blot
out the law an ex call is Ben and Ben's
listening in Sacramento California Ben
welcome to the program hi pastor Doug
hey thanks for calling your question
tonight question is romans 8:28 the
reason why i'm asking on that is because
i lost my wife last year and i was just
kind of wondering how how does that
verse pertain to well those kind of
tragedies yes yes yeah and you know I
can appreciate that I've had to stand by
the grave of many family members and
when you read the verse let me read it
for our listeners it's a famous first
Romans 8:28 and we know that all things
work together for good to them that love
God to those who are called according to
his purpose that doesn't mean that
everything that happens is good because
there's a lot of things that happened to
God is very sad about that's why we pray
thy will be done cuz a lot of times it's
not God's will that's happening and we
should be praying that it is God's will
but God can take the bad things that
happen and work them together for good
he can bring good out of it and we can
just trust him that if we say Lord I
don't know why this happened but you can
you bring good out of it an example
would be Joseph who was sold by his
brothers and now God never wanted
Joseph's brothers to betray him to sell
him as a slave to lie to their father
God never encouraged that but God took
what happened to Joseph and worked it
together for good where he ended up
becoming the prime minister of the
kingdom and saved his family and from
you know probably millions of people
from starvation
so God worked it for good and Joseph
actually said that to his brothers I
know that God allowed this to happen
that much life could be saved I don't
know what the good is that God is gonna
bring from the tragedy in your life
sometimes when we've gone through
heartache God is then able to use us to
bring comfort to others that are
grieving and so and there's even a verse
that says we comfort others with the
comfort that we get from God when we go
through grief so I don't know but God is
somehow gonna use it for good he'll make
good come from it does that make sense
yes pastor Doug thank you so very much
appreciate it all right well god bless
you and we appreciate your call been
Nicoli is Rick listening from Florida
Rick you on the air hi pastors hey
pastor Doug you said in one of your
answers earlier that the angel saw their
Savior when he was being crucified did
the Angels need a Savior that's a good
catch I that's a I misspoke I probably
could the angel songs the saver Savior
he wouldn't be their Savior from sin
because the unfallen angels are sinless
they haven't they don't need a savior
the fallen angels are you know they've
committed the unpardonable sin they've
gone too far
I don't believe Jesus died on the cross
to save angels there's nothing in the
Gospels that teaches us that so it would
be they saw their Lord because he is
their commanding creator okay thank you
so much love your show
yeah I'm glad you brought that up thank
you bye-bye my next holy is Joanna
listening from Vermont
chyna welcome to the program hi thanks
for taking my call the question I have
is did Adam and Eve died in the flood no
good question
of course they lived a long time we
don't know how long Eve lived but it
does tell us Adam lived I think it's 930
years but the flood did not come until a
little more than 1500 years after Adam
and so Adam was dead and matter of fact
Methuselah died just before the flood if
I'm not mistaken and you know we amazing
facts has a timeline where you can look
on the history of creation it's taken
all the Bible dates that's plug demand
it shows how people's lives overlap and
it's called Bible history comm am I
giving the right address pastor Ross
Bible history.com amazing facts has
about 30 websites sometimes I forget
which ones are common organ net and
you'll see that right there Pam so yeah
Oh Joanne and so take a look at that and
yeah Adam died well before the flood and
you see there's several generations that
came after him Lamech and Methuselah the
parents of Noah also died before the
flood okay history.com bible history.com
i'm looking at right here so yep sure
enough Bible history calm I'm not safe
or get you there but definitely calm
we'll get you there web site Bible
history calm if you have a Bible
question the phone line to call is 808
sorry eight hundred six three four six
three there it is seven two nine seven
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven with your Bible question then
we'll try and get that on the program
before we run out of time this evening a
next caller is Carmen listening from
Texas Carmen welcome to the program
hello oh how are y'all doing great how
about you I'm doing well thank you so
much for answering this for me I wanted
to know we had a recent death in the
family and I'm just curious will we
recognize one another after death
yeah if you look in your Bible in first
Corinthians chapter 13 Paul said that in
verse 12 matter-of-fact I just quoted
this a minute ago for now we see through
a glass darkly but then face to face now
I know in part but then meaning in
heaven I will know even as also I am
known
when we get to heaven because our minds
our bodies our spirits will all be
improved we have glorified bodies our
minds will be perfect and clear our
discernment will be enhanced we will be
able to look at a person and see who
they are in a deeper way than we can
even now because our perceptions are
gonna be greatly strengthened and so I
will guarantee you that when you get to
heaven you know if if you've had to lay
GRANDMONT to rest and she was an old
lady she will not look like an old lady
in the resurrection grandma is going to
be vibrant and young and everyone's
gonna have this you know perfect mature
look about them but we will know who
they are
there'll be instant recognition and one
reason we know this is that Christ you
know of course guided by the Holy Spirit
he knew people he'd never met before he
went underneath the tree and he knew
Zacchaeus he looked up and said
Zacchaeus and they'd never met when
Jesus saw Nathanael come to him he said
oh here's an Israelite in whom there is
no guile and
they faint I said Lord how do you know
me said I saw you under the fig tree
praying and so our discernment
the Bible says we'll have glorified
bodies like his body our discernment
will be enhanced in heaven we will
recognize our loved ones and friends
even though we maybe have been separated
by years even though we may have grown
old on earth a while they had been laid
to rest before us so I can promise you
that and the angels will have a computer
database to help put us in touch with
anyone we're missing some kind of
heavenly Facebook amen all right hey
Thank You Pam god bless good question I
know others are wondering the same thing
i next hula is Pam I think we were just
talking with Carmen but Pam is listening
from Wisconsin Pam welcome to the
program hello I
you on the air hi Pam I think the last
two callers Pam because I was looking at
your name on the screen alright and your
question this is the real Pam now
alright it's the real Pam I was calling
because I was wondering what what is
God's name I know when we say God some
people don't
well I know that the Satan is the god of
this world and some people when they say
God then that was her into the Most High
God right well there it's sort of a it
can be a deeper question because the
Lord goes by many names in the Bible you
know in the Old Testament he was called
Elohim he's called out on I yes this
famous song he's called El Shaddai he
was called Jehovah
some call it Yahweh we're not exactly
sure how to pronounce the Tetra
gammatron yet but as near as we can tell
it's something like Yahweh and then God
calls himself the the I am Jesus God the
Son is called you know many names he's
called the door the Shepherd the living
water the bread the Alpha and Omega the
bright and Morning Star there's a lot of
names that God goes by you know I have a
book Pam if you'd like I'll send you a
free copy and it's called
the name of God because people wonder
you know do I have to say a certain name
when I pray
of course we're told to pray in Christ's
name but you know doesn't matter if we
pronounce his name in English or Spanish
or do we need to pronounce his name with
the Hebrew pronunciation people have all
kinds of interesting questions about the
name of God because obviously we're not
to take his name in vain there's no name
more sacred so people want to get it
right would you like a free copy of that
pen oh sure yeah all right we'll send
you the book called the name of God the
number to call he's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and as
for the book the name of God and we'll
be happy to send that to you Pam or
anybody who calls and asks I next
holidays Oscar listening from New York
City
Oscar often to the program Oscar are you
there yet hey thank you for calling your
question tonight thank you
we according to the Bible we our body
mind and spirit right yes so at what
point of the conception does the fetus
the human fetus acquired the soul and
the spirit well I think the only place
that you can point to on the continuum
of life when human life is viable and
sacred is conception and so from the
moment I mean you know when whatever
people say all right when the when the
baby has developed and it has you know
five billion cells then we'll call it
human I think that when that spark of
life happens they've actually got video
watching conception before and something
amazing happens to a cell it's almost
like it Quivers when the an egg is
fertilized and you've got the joining of
the genes of these two independent
people that is forming a new person it's
really miraculous and even Solomon says
who can know or who can tell how the
bones do grow in the womb of her that is
with child it's a miracle you know I'm
favorites as I'm marvelously made and so
when Bathsheba came became pregnant
Bathsheba sent a letter to David and she
said I am with child well she may have
only been a few weeks along but she
didn't stand with fetus she called it a
child and so I I think you need to point
to the point of conception as when life
becomes sacred there's no baby the call
of verse that states specifically at
what point that actually happens right
well I do think that there are verses
where it talks about that when a woman
conceived that God marked that point and
when
when Sarah was with child and I think
there's there's several examples when
Zechariah and Elizabeth were with child
it I don't think you're gonna find a
scripture anywhere that says you know at
the point that the the sperm and the egg
come together that becomes a body spirit
and soul you're not going to find that
kind of verse I think it's in any cell
in any kind of cell but not spiritual
life well what do you think I'm just
curious what do you think when do you
think life becomes sacred if God says
that there is life in a womb of course
there's life because there is a human's
health you know whatever there's a human
cell it's biological life in that womb
but not necessarily that it is staying
stating that there is a spirit and a
soul or a spiritual life per se unless
it is explicitly specified well I would
think I would have to respectfully
disagree and say I think that when it's
either alive it's human life and it's
sacred and it has properties that are
made in the image of God that should be
recognized and respected or not and so
anyway we're not gonna find a verse that
will spell out what you're asking for
but I hope that helps a little how much
time do we have left we got one minute
do we have someone out there that is
willing to try a one-minute question
sure we got Bob who is listening in
Tennessee Bob welcome to the program
we've got about a minute good question
but I think what you meant to say when
Cain got kicked out of the garden from
after he killed his brother where'd he
get his wife from well you read on later
it tells us in Genesis chapter 5 that
Adam and Eve also had sons and daughters
many of them and very likely Cain
married one of his sisters it shouldn't
surprise us Abraham married a
half-sister Jacob married a first cousin
hey we are out of time friends we hope
you've been blessed by the program we do
have some important announcements
coming along the way I hope that you'll
recognize amazing facts is only on the
channel and you're listening to right
now because somebody made a donation to
keep us there go to amazing facts dot
o-r-g and tell us you're listening we'd
love to hear from you
god bless we'll look forward to studying
his word together again in our next
broadcast
thank you for listening to today's
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
throughout recorded history tales of
ghosts and spirits can be found in
folklore in nearly every country and
culture the Egyptians built pyramids to
help guide the spirits of their leaders
Rome sanctioned holidays to honor and
appease the spirits of their dead even
the Bible tells of a king that used a
witch to contact the spirit of a
deceased prophet today ancient folklore
of spirits and apparitions have gone
from mere superstitions to mainstream
entertainment and reality scientific
organisations investigate stories of
hauntings and sightings trying to prove
once and for all the existence of ghosts
even with all the newfound technology
and centuries of stories all over the
world there is still no clear-cut answer
so how do we know what's true why do
these stories persist does it even
matter
we invite you to look inside and find
out for yourself visit death truth calm
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG did you enjoy this
program make sure to tell your family
and friends tune in next time for more
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions